hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2004 chinese action and fantasy movie
called kung fu hustle
the movie takes place in 1940 shanghai
where local gangsters are beating up the
police officers after they arrested the
boss's beautiful wife just for spitting
no one dares to retaliate as he shouts
at the police chief
they walk out of the building but feel
something strange as the cars on the
street are missing
suddenly a horde of the notorious rival
gang called axe gang surrounds them
while all local people shut all their
doors and windows as they are afraid of
the gang
they start shooting ruthlessly at the
gangsters leaving the gang boss alone he
attempts to run away but one of the
black suited man throws an axe towards
him cutting off his leg he begs for
mercy but the cold-blooded axe-gang
leader brother sum ignores him and
begins to chop him repeatedly after that
the axe gang orders the corrupt local
officers to clean up the mess
to celebrate their victory against their
rival the gangsters start dancing
awkwardly while keeps terrorizing the
town with their signature weapon an axe
the scene moves to the poorest district
in the country pigsty alley where
everyone lives peacefully as no gang is
interested to rule over since the
district cannot generate any profits
the place is owned by a landlord who
seems to be drunk all the time and loves
to flirt with the people and his grumpy
wife whose hobby is shouting at the
tenants and smacking people
one of the residents runs out of the
water while having a bath but gets
slapped in the face instead after
complaining to the landlady
meanwhile the husband attempts to spy on
girls in the bathroom but gets caught
and gets beaten up ruthlessly by the
landlady
a few moments later amateur crooks sing
in his fat companion bone visit pigsty
alley and directly head over to the
barbershop hoping that they can
blackmail someone there
they attempt to extort the handsome
barber while pretending to be one of the
axe gang members
however their plan fails as he shows no
fear at all and starts calling the other
residents
despite getting cornered singh
challenges one of them to a duel
he realizes that he has chosen the wrong
district when each resident has their
own uniqueness he even gets beaten up by
an old lady he then decides to escape
but the landlady appears and starts
hitting him repeatedly
feeling threatened singh tries to bluff
he throws a firecracker claiming that he
is calling back up
unfortunately the explosion hits the
real axe gang underboss who walks
towards him with an army of black suited
gangsters
singh provokes them informing the
underboss that one of the residents was
the thrower the fierce lamb lady
realizes that she is in trouble and
begins to flee back to her room the
handsome barber makes things worse when
he shows up and somehow strikes the
underboss with mysterious force leaving
him dying inside a barrel
the gang calls for the real backup and
suddenly the district is surrounded by
the gangsters who begin to terrorize the
innocent residents they drag a woman and
his son pouring them with gasoline and
threatening to burn them alive brother
some demands the killer of the underboss
to surrender but no one shows up just
after he throws lighter a man called
coolly appears claiming that he is the
culprit cooley then attacks the emerging
gangsters with his high kick knocking
them out one by one soon after a nerd
tenant called taylor shows up to help
his friend
their weapons are useless against the
tenants as donut shows up and destroys
all the rifles with spears
turns out that all of them are kung fu
masters and the gangsters have no chance
to defeat them after a long and
one-sided fight all of them are defeated
and the remaining gangsters attempt to
retreat desperately in the axe gang hq
sing and bone are captured for causing
the embarrassment brother sum is furious
ordering his henchman to eliminate them
immediately
however singh manages to free himself
before his face is slashed by thrown
axes the boss is impressed with his
lock-picking skill and allows them to
join the gang but only after they
successfully kill someone
singh plans to kill one of the residents
at pigsty alley to prove himself but
bone questions his intention since all
of them are masters at kung fu
he then flashbacks to his childhood when
he bought a martial arts tutorial book
called the buddhist palm from a peddler
after being told that he was born with a
special kung fu aura after reading the
manual thoroughly and practicing heart
he attempts to use the technique to save
a mute girl from being bullied by older
boys but instead he gets beaten up and
humiliated
since then he withdraws his intention to
be a hero and chooses to be a bad guy
not long after they spot a lady selling
ice cream
they pretend to buy ice cream but later
run away just after they receive the
cones the next day these losers return
to pigsty alley where singh tries to
kill the landlady from a distance with a
knife but it backfires as the knife
bounces back and stabs him instead the
landlady sees them and bone attempts to
throw the snake cage but accidentally
releasing the snakes which kiss bing in
the lips sing runs away but is chased by
the landlady until somehow he manages to
dodge her and escape safely
he hides in the traffic control pulpit
for a while where his wounds are rapidly
healed and slowly starts releasing his
inner kung fu aura without him realizing
that on the other side brother some
hires two cold-blooded assassins to take
care of the fighters at pigsty alley the
harpists who turn out to be blind
mention about the best assassin in the
world called the beast who is now locked
up in an asylum because of his obsession
with kung fu
later that night cooley decides to leave
the district when he coincidentally
comes across one of the harpist
assassins
he ignores him and keeps walking as
stuff around him starts to break however
it is too late for him to react as the
harpist manages to finish him off just
with the sound waves
meanwhile the other assassin sneaks into
taylor's place and attacks him taylor
who plans to retire from fighting is
forced to fight back which causes a mess
outside the building the other blind
harpist has been waiting for him
he starts playing the instrument while
unleashing sharp sound waves toward the
old man
the assassin attacks him repeatedly
until donut chose to give assistance he
manages to block all the incoming
attacks with his spears and is able to
launch a counter-attack towards the
assassins but it doesn't last long as
the harpists speed up on launching the
deadly sound waves the fighters
eventually have their energy drained and
the foes launch their final strike
towards them but the noises make the
landlady angry and she uses his
screaming technique which disperses the
sound wave and terrifies the assassins
the landlord also suddenly appears and
starts playing around with his flexible
body
he makes the harpists attack each other
until they are overwhelmed they grab the
harp back and prepare to unleash their
best attack but the landlady casually
shows up and shows her screaming ability
defeating the assassins in style
unfortunately taylor and donut die in
the process and the whole district
including the landowners mourn for them
the next day sing and bone spot the same
ice cream vendor
singh threatens her and throws her to
the ground ordering her to give all her
money to him but the girl cries since
she doesn't expect that she is robbed by
the guy who once saved her life from the
bullies
the mute girl shows the same lollipop
from many years ago to him
singh recognizes her but doesn't feel
remorse at all as he throws the lollipop
away and leaves
afterwards the desperate sing is
suddenly taken away by black suited
gangsters
brother some admits him as a gang member
and gives him a job he is then brought
to a mental asylum where he is tasked to
release the beast who is locked up in
the safest cell of the building
he explores asylum and eventually
arrives at an underground bunker
he utilizes his lock-picking skill to
unlock the metal door and is very
surprised when he finds out that the top
killer is just a weak old man
the beast is brought to the axe casino
where no one believes in his
capabilities including the boss
to prove himself he lets a gangster
punch him ruthlessly he even grabs a gun
from the gangster and points it towards
his own head
he pulls the trigger and somehow manages
to catch the bullet effortlessly
at the same time the beast senses a
worthy opponent's presence inside the
casino and starts wrecking havoc which
terrified the whole casino players turns
out that it is the landlord and the
landlady who pay a visit to eliminate
the axe gang
the couple also bring a funeral bell as
a gift for brother some
the beast challenges the couple and the
fight between them begins
even though it is a two versus one fight
it seems like the couple are struggling
to beat the old man
the landlady uses his signature
screaming ability the lion's roar but
the beast barely moves from his standing
realizing that they cannot beat him with
bare hands the couple break the head of
the giant bell and utilize it to
generate enormous power on the roar
the screaming destroys the whole casino
and effectively hurts the beast
surprisingly the old man survives the
attack thus the couple begins to unleash
the second roar but he admits defeat
however when the couple lower their
guard the beast attacks them with sharp
sticks and manages to stab them in the
stomach
the fight continues and the three
eventually are immobilized in an inter
joint lock
at this point sing is ordered by brother
some to break the stalemate he grabs the
wooden beam and initially hits him on
the head as he is confused
after that singh stupidly hits the beast
instead of the couple
this action enraged the old man who
immediately breaks free and savagely
punches sing in the face
the landlord and landlady use this
opportunity to escape while also taking
sing with them as well
the wounded brother some yells at the
beast accusing him of letting the couple
escape
fed up he ends the boss's life just with
one arm swing
the couple bring sing back to pigsty
alley and immediately wrap him with
bandages
they are confused how this man can
withstand such damage and is still alive
they are also amazed with his recovery
speed
not long after the beast and other
gangsters arrive at the district which
has been fully abandoned by its
residents
singh surprisingly shows up with his
body fully recovered as nothing happened
turns out that the punches earlier have
unlocked sings in her talent and now he
has become a kung fu master
several minutes ago he was a loser but
now he manages to eliminate all the
gangsters effortlessly
he kicks the black suited men just as he
is playing football
after all the gangsters are defeated he
confronts the beast and launches a high
kick but the man still manages to
withstand the kick and fights back
after exchanging some punches singh
successfully knocks him down
realizing that he is no match for him
the old man transforms himself into
frogman the toad style and gains
enormous power and speed
he strikes singh with his bald head
sending him high into the sky he
continues to fly in the atmosphere until
he slows down and sees a cloud forming
as buddha as he charges down at a very
high speed towards the old man he uses
the buddha's palm ability to attack him
the force forms a huge palm on the
ground while severely crushing the beast
as expected he immediately surrenders
and tries to attack singh with a stick
but he sees that coming and unleashes
another buddha palm right beside him
damaging the whole building behind them
this time the beast really admits defeat
in tears for the first time
as the time goes by sing and bone open
up an ice cream store where sing and the
mute girl reunite
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching